this is an om stone or ogham stone
depending on whose pronunciation you
follow the carvings on here are from an
alphabet unlike anything else in the
world an alphabet that is literally an
exception to modern rules I'm not
talking about the Roman letters on the
face I'm talking about the markings
carved into the corner those markings
are in om it's a way of writing down the
early Irish language with marks like
these there are only about 400 surviving
stones like this found in Ireland and
the western parts of the UK this
particular one is about 1500 years old
and it comes from Devon in the southwest
of England it's on display here in the
British Museum the inscription is a
named ohm stones are mostly used to
record names either as a tombstone or as
a marker of land ownership you read this
along the stem line along the corner
each character is made of 1 to 5
markings which will all be on one side
of the line the other side of the mine
through the line or on the line when
modern scholars start to analyze this
script they want to write it down on
paper and they adapted it a little to
make it easier for them they changed it
so it always went left to right and each
phrase was drawn on a horizontal line
see if it easily tell which marks were
on which side some arm inscriptions on
latest stones or on other artifacts do
actually carve their own stem line into
a flat surface so adding that line in
print wasn't too much of a stretch and
after all trying to fold a bit of paper
and sketch markings on the corner
wouldn't be easy to work with rakha
Demick papers and that left us years
later with an interesting technology
problem when it came time to encode own
characters as ones and zeros to fold
them into unicode the international
standard for how to display text on a
computer
Owen became the only language in Unicode
where a space is not a space a space
character to a computer has three
properties it has a certain width you
don't display or print anything in that
width and if your text has run out of
room on a line you can go back to the
previous space character and replace it
with a line break now there have been
well understood variations on those for
years two of those rules are flattered
all the time you can have a non-breaking
space I like the one between a word and
a french quotation mark that space has
width it has nothing displayed in it but
you can't put a line break there the
word in the punctuation must travel
together you can also have a zero width
space which sounds like
ridiculous idea but it's a good way to
tell a computer that if there isn't room
it's okay to break a long string of
characters somewhere that it otherwise
wouldn't these are all commonly used but
until Olin was added to Unicode the rule
that a space character must be empty had
never been broken why would it's it's a
space well an arm space includes that
stem line the line doesn't stop between
words because the corner doesn't stop
between words the space is not a space
but it behaves like one it can be
replaced with a line break if you've
spread an om inscription over two lines
the space character vanishes same as in
English now om isn't the only language
that uses a separator like this ancient
Latin uses an inter pact a middle dot
the same way but in modern usage that is
not a space and modern usage wings om is
the only case where modern folks have
gone yeah okay it's a space that also
involves drawing something it's a space
that isn't a space there's been an
actual argument about it down in one of
the mailing lists for linguists and
computer science nerds at the Unicode
consortium the Irish contingent had some
very strong opinions and the final
ruling yeah it's a space that's also a
line this is one of the things that I
love about linguistics an ancient script
carved into stones more than a
millennium ago is an exception to a rule
that I never even realized was there a
space doesn't have to be a space
you